Challenge is the actual rooftop and if
you're to fall off this rooftop you have
like a 99% chance of dying so I have to
get back to set that steam shooting
lifeline like to leave this project of
the handshake and rent they had 10 days
to this done they have day of prep 2
days of shooting two days of editing and
then one week to do all the sound music
color grading visual effects basically
they have to get done in a very short
amount of time so it's really up to Jake
and rent to work together Ren has all
the visual stuff figured out he knows
how he's going to do all the effects
whereas takes the early effects guy but
he can run and shoot really well the
main thing is this is this is the first
time audible of sponsoring a video on
the corridor channel and audible is
pretty good at letting people do their
own creative ideas that's opposed to
having to make the whole thing and
advertise it so we really like working
with them and we really want to keep
working with them so hopefully Jake and
Ren do a good job on this top floor all
right
we're trying to get this input shot
figured out businesses that they place
on a rooftop in this show here we are on
the rooftop we're going to be shooting
here we are
challenge is the actual rooftop but we
need seems that the actors are sitting
on the edge of the roof actually have
scenes actually standing on the roof
it's these electrics fall off the edge
of the roof and so we can interlace VFX
magic land which costs way too much
money or just enter stunt wire magic
land with some really time-consuming
week so I got to think of a solution
alright and in real space there's
obviously nothing there I'm literally
just walking through a wall but that's
in that equation you like I'm in very
good club to tag and you're like oh I'm
gonna tag here you can't do it for
another place especially for focusing on
just the wall we can literally just put
up a light about the camera next to
light and put the people in front of the
light but the people are just offering
from your camera so we're literally just
looking at their shadows so like this
should be a hundred sent and we should
throw some different lights just some
different distances Brett backpack Yanks
from his back
that's just practical string tied to the
back tied to the bag the demon pulls him
again try it practically will be it
we'll know in a little bit
cut it out I'm sure we'll have enough
light I think I got to figure it out so
we built this here creature we actually
replicated these walls on this platform
and raised it all up Oh so we could go
up there and filmed Eve on the ledge
with the cityscape behind them and it
looks like they're on the edge of the
roof but they're actually not it was
actually a relatively elegant and simple
solution that gets us from filming on
the real ledge and filming on the fake
ledge yeah come here it looks really
sitting on the edge of the roof of Nikko
that's like 12 or do you want to look up
duty calls for itself
it's tricky because we're on the say
group we can't show the fact there's
another roof be on the show guys let's
roll camera please
great nice work
so there was certain amount of time
every day from the scenes and the time
each step takes about half an hour you
know it's a puzzle taking all this
dialogue and breaking it down so that
cover each character in the faces if you
have to camera streets you're basically
looking at one angle establishing the
space here we get close-ups in you're
doing a wide because they'd be able to
get the microphone in the shots what do
we do the close-ups like if it's two
cells who need it stylize it a little
bit so that shows interesting to watch
we're trying to set up both cameras here
a dolly shot and then this shot but
probably gonna see this camera from the
dolly but thankfully we have enough time
to do one into the other we have time to
see what happens in our third set of
labs on like a dolly moving camera or
something else that maybe comes up with
just something I come up with get the
show looking awesome
whether it's he were saying today Ben's
in New York filming with Dwayne the rock
Johnson yeah yes be there for three days
waiting for a 20-minute window to film
with a rock but did you a tree eight
hanging out the rock attorney knows so
this light is going to be our prop light
if you also you know work it's a light
but we're not going to depend on this
buddy actually shadows that we do this
deal with sudden we're actually using a
more advanced piece of technology known
as LED lighting Thank You shark we're
going to be shooting this all on sticks
which means like tripod engines and
dollies I don't really know what to
expect right so let's go through the
blocking really quick come in flip
around the grandeur of this old
warehouse one of the demons brass but
they physically grab you though they
grab your shadow and that affects you by
cop of you like get back and this base
is your death position if you like this
oh and even and then our end comes in
right after that and defines your back
on the ground like the lightness here
that's from the the light reflecting off
of our reflective ground up and kind of
making the shadow a little bit less
opaque and so with the do between there
that's absorbing the reflected light so
that we get a nice harsh shut up what's
up guys is Sydney Park here
she's like Nora on lifeline wants to ask
you a couple questions
I'm actually kind of curious your on
walking dead right yeah so how does how
does a set of walking dead compared to
this set okay well your setup set of
walking dead we are in Georgia in the
woods there are no sound stages we're
working with the heat were working with
humidity it's a really like big crew
obviously because it's a huge production
but it when it's dark
no games are played it's just this like
fun and friendly as it is here everybody
you know
it's so close knit and we work very
closely together and that's what I've
loved about both sets definitely been so
much fun and working on this bed and you
know you and Sam set a really great tone
oh yeah they're going to be directing
Marvel's doing a lot of their events
even on the set of walking duplicate I
have I heard that you guys have worked
with him he's in me I have a really
funny story about him actually
yeah and said she was running to get
some like shrimp pad thai for me and my
mom so I'm like great that's so cool you
know I'm going to come downstairs with
like cash and give him the whole [ __ ]
right and I just met him maybe like 15
minutes before it turned around like all
sweaty
it was bright face and this big white
smile he's like hi I'm Steven I was like
yes you are
I think hi Steven nice to meet you comes
to hotel you know he's act like the food
and sherry the teamster was like driving
us wait finish the damn story it's so
good all right that's good this time
when you push the bottle lean on the
ledge and watch it fall all the way down
to the imaginary street great I think
the beetle good you think about my image
to like show that resolution the two
things that come to mind is you know the
term like setting your jaw
yeah so you try that what's like you
know or it means a fire I wish I had a
beer to work with yeah yeah thank you
everybody makes it so much more dramatic
you fiction work right right doctor name
is Bulls are and your mission is
peaceful looks like your one mission in
life okay Emma ghoul what's your name
Gulzar what's your mission so what's
your name goals are what's your mission
eats already man you're ready you one
action
your ring your breast but for a little
bit by taking gaff tape attaching it to
a piece of cardboard sticking that
cardboard right on his cheeks that when
I pull them across the floor his 200
pounds doesn't affect me as much easier
he looks calm there - there it is again
oh it's gone wait so your favorite story
real quick okay so even though I've
almost took my shrimp pad thai and I'm
standing there and he's like here you go
and he's like he opens it and he's
looking at he's like oh yeah that was
good and he's giving me like a look I'm
like what do you want to do right so
let's do it here's like reluctantly
gaming so that's my seat auditory get to
work with him yet so most of our food
and so he was so sweet and generous he
bought it for me really well like let me
give you cash he's like no no no no take
it and sherry the drivers like he's
trying to be nice sweetheart I was like
oh okay thank you thank you we shall
finish filming the magic will commence
Oh magic magic so much since this
concept is based around kind of like a
monster demon we want to give them claws
so I'm going to show you a cheap
convenient and pretty easy way to you
make demon claws how I mean is a regular
piece of paper you take your piece of
paper to look at it portrait wise take
your right end and fold all the way
across and increase now we're getting to
it a series of triangle that so then you
take your left side that you've made
your point
connecting it to this crease here so
this is the triangle you want to get to
but we also don't want to waste paper
fold it up here fold it up here and tuck
it up face your base shape but now that
we're at the triangle all we do is take
our point again
point right down the middle to make the
shape of your cloth but it's not really
you can really stick your finger and
it's not actually a claw yet but it's
starting to take its shape what you do
here is just fold over all the excess
paper and it only really takes two folds
so one to change your shape almost there
but you're going to have this little
extra flap all you got to do is tuck it
in there kind of make sure it's nice and
tight fold it and all that did was make
a nice little pocket for your finger so
you just open this up make you taking
shape BAM we got a nice monster call
with that kind of that scary-looking
knuckle kind of similar to a ring race
in Lord of the Rings or something like
that hey you know who's Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau his favorite
youtube channel is the nerdwriter
Channel one of my favorites as well in
fact my favorite video that he's put out
is the one talking about helms deep from
the two towers it's an awesome video
really kind of analyzing and
deconstructing just how it is as a scene
and how that's just great storytelling
in general I recommend you check that
out at the end of this video a 39 minute
sequence it has to carry the dramatic
weight the ups and downs of a mini movie
within a movie to hold our attention
intelligibility is really important for
a giant set piece like this not only do
you want the audience to be able to see
what's happening you want them to have a
sense of how the fighting is developing
for each side